now what kind of parent sends their
five-year-old to school in nappies
unable to speak in sentences take off
their own coat wash their hands or hold
a pencil I'll tell you a reckless
irresponsible one who'd rather stick
their kids in front of tablets and
Playstations then teach them how to read
speak or go to the toilet but at many
schools this is exactly what's happening
and in a damning indictment of
modern-day parenting Ofsted bas Amanda
Spearman has told parents they're
setting their kids up to fail and she's
right how dare parents put their kids at
such a disadvantage at such an early age
how dare they expect the state to assume
parenting responsibilities by
subcontracting that role to nurseries
teachers and carers parents are their
kids first teacher and while it is a
teacher's job to provide academic
knowledge and maybe help reinforce
social and personal behaviors it
definitely isn't their job to wipe poopy
backsides and teach basic speech and
hygiene skills that responsibility lies
smack bang with pens and if they aren't
prepared to take it on
why have kids in the photo trouble
Cowell is everyone would agree with you
but but how do you change a society
where that is I mean let's not kid
ourselves
this isn't most parents most parents
actually they're saying as a small
increase that's not I don't
no one's gonna disagree with you that
actually there is a job of parenting but
well I don't know is how you change this
without initiatives that cost money
which you never want to pay for because
now whenever once more taxes and without
some I mean sure start would have been a
help onesie that was scrapped no it is
about I think you're also right about
somehow you've got to get it at kids as
they become yeah yeah do you fine yes
today will be pain take them your child
has stopped this school this night then
is the child that suffers well that's up
to the parent to sort it out quickly
well how societies is a long time ago
that was actually inadequate parenting
meant that the society had to step in
but if you're a teacher who wants to do
didn't sign up to wipe a 3 or 4 year old
Charles backside did not read I have no
evidence for this I'm just assuming that
but I bet you that is the majority of
middle class and affluent parents whose
kids are the ones going to do you do
good because poor parents can't afford
nappies therefore they just pack that
little interesting because I have
something to say about that let me just
say this middle-class parents there's a
nappy that that you can wear my future
schooling and it's much more expensive
than than the ones that the poor opinion
foster yes you're right yeah
no I've noticed I mean things I agree I
didn't think children should be allowed
to start school and be out you can't
outsource potty training to a nursery
school teachers it's unthinkable
I mean schools in some instance I know
what he's trained three children and I
think the experience I kind of can't
remember how I did it but I I somehow
managed and that is called dry and they
you know all of that now what's going on
at the moment and that's why it's so
interesting you racist meadow crossing
there's this new trend called attachment
parenting what is that which is where
you take the lead from your child and so
when your child decides what baby wants
you know lunch or supper all that baby
wants the baby has to lead the way
that's where your best reading until the
child is six oh and also you see
children going to school in nappies and
and if you're the parent grandparent you
can't say enough they can't get in
because you'll have your head [ __ ]
your grandpa just lost three months I
know why do you interfere at your pal
yeah but I don't my experience of
watching these kids is there isn't like
this at all they actually go through the
process that had potty training the rest
of it and I think I'm talking I know a
three-year-old at the movies didn't know
we shouldn't assume that this is
everywhere is in enough places that it
is rising has comments on this three
years in a row and what she said is 84%
of her teachers or have have noted an
increase in this and also 70% in
teachers got worse over the past five
let's just look at a piece of foam here
from a lady called Liat Hughes joshing
she's a parenting expert clearly
something like toilet training is a
private matter that should be dealt with
our home and I can see Amanda Spearman's
frustration on the part of schools and
teachers about this issue because even
if you have a handful of children who
are turning up at school in each class
who are not toilet trained and have have
problems with other self-care tasks like
feeding themselves teachers have to mop
that up literally in some cases you know
the tragic thing here is that in poor
you know kids are going to school not
being able to talk and we demand the
nappies but poor literacy holds a kid
back at every single session what
happens is those kids are behind in
Changi office when they leave school
they instructor get a job they may have
kids in the same thing [ __ ] weights
itself so we've got gonna have a nation
of kids that can't do your basics
yes finding would work because I agree
with you as a nature we come I sense
from good parents we parented good kids
I know parents taking kids away on
holiday during the social year yeah it's
work there it wasn't no I did that for
you well you can afford to
by any fine someone I just got somebody
I just felt a then it was the same
speech from someone called Marc Creasy
who's gonna stick up for these poor
parents who are being assailed on I
think there's lots of pressures on
parents and actually we don't look as a
society of what we are actually doing to
parents which then has a knock-on effect
to what goes on in schools parents are
very time poor
so therefore things are shifting on to
schools to try and plug the gaps
many parents now don't have the family
support the grandparents the aunts and
uncles that we used to have in decades
gone by I don't think schools and
parents could be set up against each
other we should be working in
partnership and the best schools
actually do that it can't one can't help
thinking that actually parents just
think the whole job is going to the
schools had three jobs and I was off the
potty by the time I was two most towns
and the number of obvious grandparents
because because childcare in this
country so expensive this is the point
but no you say there's none it's chief
Ofsted is has thought for the past three
years in a row got it is bringing about
a 70 percent increase the trouble is we
don't know what the base of it was five
I was an old counterfeit journalist
amused you that make a she said if
there's three in every class I can
believe that I can move it and there but
what you do about it and how you mind
you I don't know I certainly don't think
start finding them and stopping them
leave that with the visual of Carol on
her courtiers I should have said
it is terrible before we go there's just
time for this like many of you I'm
looking forward to Christmas dinner
around the family it's going to be very
harmonious the only downside is it's
often a nightmare trying to get a word
in edgeways so this week I was relieved
to find that I'm not the only one to
experience this frustration watch for
conservative MP sir Raja Gayle sitting
behind my brother in the Commons witness
ring in defiance of the wishes and we
should be careful about we should be
careful I'll give away to my honourable
friend behind me who's been Chung Turing
away through a sedentary position no one
campaign no one voted for this type of
Breck so this isn't brexit this is not
similar national independence it is AI
will differ it I'll give way to save
this Germany I'm very grateful to the
right of the gentleman for giving away
yeah obviously one of those who prefers
the grievance to the solution my right
arm or friend the Prime Minister has
come up with a solution
what's his big idea for your
perseverance Sir Roger you win our award
for heckler of the week and I give way
to Carol do you think you might be
having your Christmas dinner and down
the street this year maybe I think it
could be it ends up and down yeah we've
got so many more brothers where those
two came next generation on the one